ukraine
was a flawed democracy
before russia invaded
it's utterly corrupt
many ways dysfunctional especially the
elites were dysfunctional
the gas industry in ukraine was
absolutely terrible because of the
corruption that it generated the
oligarch problem
a handful of people stealing the state
resources and yet ukraine had an open
public sphere
and it had a parliament that functioned
and so despite its flaws
it was still
a democracy the regime in moscow you
can't say that lex
it's not a comparable regime to ukraine
you could say oh well there are
oligarchs in ukraine and there are
oligarchs in russia there's corruption
in ukraine there's corruption in russia
so really what's the big difference
the answer is well
ukraine had the open public sphere
ukraine had a real apartment can you
call russia's duma
a real parliament i don't think so
i don't think you can
can you say that there were any checks
whatsoever on the executive branch
in russia can you say that the russian
judiciary had any independence
or really
full level of competence
even compared to the ukrainian judiciary
which was nothing to brag about no you
can't say that lex
so we can differentiate
between
the very flawed corrupt oligarch
oligarchic democracy in ukraine
and the very corrupt oligarchic
autocracy in russia i think that's a
fair distinction yeah we should say that
russia and ukraine have the great honor
of being the number one and the number
two most corrupt nations in europe by
many measures
but there is a fundamental difference as
you're highlighting
uh russia is a corrupt autocracy
ukraine we can say is a corrupt
democracy
and um to that level there's a the
there's a fundamental difference
ukraine is not murdering
its own journalists
in systematic fashion if journalists are
killed in ukraine it's a tragedy if
journalists are killed in russia or
russian journalists are killed abroad
it's regime policy and the degree to
which a nation is authoritarian
means that it's suffocating its own
spirit it's capacity to flourish it's uh
we're not just talking about
sort of um
the freedom of the press those kinds of
things but basically all industries
get suffocated and you're no longer
being able to
yeah flourish as a nation grow the the
production the gdp the scientists the
art the culture all those kinds of
things yes lex you're absolutely right
and so
before the invasion the full-blown
invasion of february 2022 into ukraine
because as you know the war has been
going on for many years at a lower level
compared to what it is these days but
still a tragic war with many deaths
prior to february 2022
before this latest war we could have
said that the greatest victims of the
putin regime are russian
domestic
that the the people who are suffering
the most from the putin regime
are not sitting here in new york city
but in fact they're sitting there in
russia
now of course with the invasion of
ukraine and and really
the
atrocities that have been well
documented
and more are being investigated
we can't easily say anymore that
russians are the greatest victims of the
putin regime
but in in ways other than bombing and
murdering civilians
children mothers
grandmothers grandfathers
after you include that
then of course the larger number of
victims of the putin regime are not
ukrainians but ultimately russians and
and there's how many of them now that
have fled
you